à 9h sur public sénat
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à bruxelles au parlement européen
pour cette nouvelle édition de rap hebdo
fait dans cette émission nous allons en
espagne dans le nord du pays
exactement et on va le voir le vin
espagnol a la cote
tellement la cote qu'il dope les
exportations des exportations qui font
un bond en avant dans d'autres domaines
aussi alors peut-être la fin du tunnel
peut-on parler de sortie de crise en
espagne
il faut rester prudent on verra cela
avec nos invités
mais d'abord l'actualité ce sont les
roms cette population qui n'arrivent pas
à s'intégrer en france c'est le ministre
français de l'intérieur qu'il dit
attention attention liberté de
circulation et d'installation répond la
commission européenne
un débat vous le voyez qui provoque
l'hystérie sont ils devenus fous
au centre de la polémique les roms un
des derniers peuples transnationaux et
sans état la plupart des vingt mille
roms installés en france vient de
roumanie à gauche vous avez manuel valls
le ministre français de l'intérieur son
message les roms ne peuvent pas
s'intégrer en france
les roms ont vocation à rester dans leur
pays et à s'y intégrer
là bas à droite la commission européenne
outré par de tels propos
sa vice présidente ouvre les hostilités
j'entends tout simplement été discours
que je clarifie dans la catégorie
campagne électorale à chaque fois qu'on
veut ne pas parler des choses
importantes on trouve de nouveau les
roms et rebelote quelques heures après
là c'est un officiel de la commission
européenne qui recadre sèchement le
ministre français de l'intérieur le
rappelle que la commission fait à la
france mais aussi aux autres états
membres que ils se ils ont accordé entre
eux et avec la commission
une stratégie européenne visant à
l'intégration des roms l'intégration
dans le pays où il souhaite résider et
pas uniquement dans le pays de leur
nationalité
voici que l'on parle des roms et voilà
l'hystérie collective qui s'empare des
autorités françaises et européennes sont
ils devenus fous
sont ils devenus fous telle est la
question alors nous as a rejoint sur ce
plateau cristian preda bonjour vous êtes
députés eurodéputés
romain vous êtes au groupe ppe ici au
parlement européen à bruxelles alors on
a vraiment le sentiment que le débat sur
les roms crispent les esprits est ce que
vous comprenez qui crispe autant les
esprits en france
malheureusement oui c'est un 7-1
crispation qui a vécu quand on l'a on
l'a vu déjà il ya deux trois ans et à
l'épaule d'elle il y avait toujours un
dialogue entre la commission d'un côté
avec madame reding
et puis le président de l'époque sarkozy
mais non on a l'impression de revoir ce
film avec simplement les socialistes
aujourd'hui les dommages la même
situation alors les discussions les
mêmes et j'allais dire il n'y a pas de
nouveauté dans dance électronique
il ya là la proche de la campagne pour
les municipales en france tout ce qui
est un peu différent dans le décor vue
qui a on le sait en lisant la presse
française en voyant ce qui ce qui est le
débat en france il ya un certain
préoccupations des municipalités parce
que ce sont les maires ce sont les
communautés locales qui sont en direct
interaction avec avec ces roms venus de
roumanie ce qu'on comprend ce débat est
ce qu'on compense cette crise crispation
est ce que l'avion roumanie auparavant
il ya un côté que je veux marquer c'est
vraiment triste pour moi de voir les
relations franco-roumaines un peu
dégradé par un jeu ce dialogue parce que
c'est un dialogue qui est maintenant
très offensif et keane qui ne
ne tourne pas autour de l'idée d'une
coopération y compris avec la commission
européenne c'est plutôt dans un dialogue
qu'on vous dit crispée et agressive et
c'est dommage parce qu'on avait
d'excellentes relations de l'arménie de
la france maintenant en roumanie il y à
la perception de ce dialogue avec une
complication supplémentaire vu que le
premier ministre est maintenant
socialiste il a devant lui en france des
amis socialistes qui l'avaient soutenu
le premier ministre roumain était
à l'un des participants à la campagne
d'hollande et puis maintenant personne
ne comprend plus en roumanie ce qui se
passe pourquoi est ce que les
socialistes à leur tour ont abandonné un
discours plus modéré plus tolérants
qu'il tenait au moment où sarko ou
sarkozy était président donc il ya une
couche supplémentaire d'incompréhension
ja ja l'édile une stigmatisation
supplémentaire des roms
ce qui ne va pas vraiment contribué à
l'amélioration de la gestion du sort de
ces populations
d'autant plus que depuis la création des
ressources importantes au niveau
européen il n'y a pas ni en france ni en
roumanie malheureusement une
augmentation par exemple du nombre des
associations qui gèrent ce problème il
ya des fonds importants fonds de
cohésion au fonds de développement rural
et malheureusement il n'y a pas un accès
suffisant qui permettent des vraies
avancées dans la gestion des problèmes
très concrets comme l'habitation l'accès
à l'eau la scolarisation de tout ces
gens là donc malheureusement on est dans
un poids mort et tout ce qu'on voit
c'est avec sa seule passion d'aider des
passions politiques
cristian preda on a vu le problème côté
côté français on va devoir maintenant
côté côté roumain je vous propose
d'écouter tout de suite j'ai lu de
minutieux il s'occupe beaucoup des roms
du côté de bucarest on est partis
l'interroger dans la capitale roumaine
et vous allez voir pour lui les
autorités roumaines ne font pas tout ce
qu'elles peuvent pour retenir les roms
en roumanie et pour cause écouter
les autorités ont intérêt à ce qu'il y
ait une forte communauté à l'extérieur
du pays quand on regarde les
statistiques tous les ans les roumains c
incluent les roms qui sont à l'étranger
envoient un milliard deux cent mille
euros c'est une somme qui représente 1 %
du pib saper le système éducatif
le système de santé en roumanie tous les
salaires sont payés grâce à cet argent
alors chris hohn près d'alès que c'est
une politique voulue ont fait partir les
roms parce qu'on sait qu'ils vont venir
et qui rapportent beaucoup de devises
étrangères qui font vivre l'économie
roumaine
bon maintenant il faut voir quand même
si le côté statistiques de la chose si
les statistiques publiées en france il
ya une semaine son vrai j'ai vu qu'ils
avaient investissement de quelque 15
mille roms s'installent
enfin du point de vue strictement
quantitatif c'est presque lien par
rapport à la population de presque 2,5
millions de roumains qui vivent à
l'étranger et qui envoie c'est vrai
chaque année des sources importantes de
l'autre côté ça a été clair les roms qui
partent sont généralement des gens très
pauvres qui n'en voient pas de l'agent
armani donc on n'est pas sur un terrain
trop trop trop trop clair ici sur un
discours très clair c'est vrai qu'il ya
une déficience dans la gestion des
problèmes
des roms notamment parce que il faut
dire en roumanie il n'y a qu'une
vingtaine de l'association par exemple
qui sont au travail et dans la gestion
de ces problèmes pour une population rom
qui est estimé à environ 8 millions de
personnes en roumanie c'est pas facile
vous voyez de la grandeur des
difficultés parce que si vous avez 1,8
millions de roms en roumanie ce que
disent nos statistiques et si vous avez
quinze mille en france
j'allais dire l'effort pour pour
vraiment intégrer ces populations est
beaucoup plus plus grands devait être
beaucoup plus que la roumanie qu'en
france c'est l'ordre des difficultés et
unie européenne a débloqué jeu si je ne
m'abuse 50 milliards d'euros pour
l'intégration des roms dans tout dans
tous les états les états ne les
utilisent pas c'est nautilis pas cet
argent pourquoi
voilà ces nouveaux j'espère que ça va ça
va s'améliorer
déjà c'est important de disposer de ses
ressources et donc si je veux dire si le
les passions politiques ce n'est un peu
plus modérée était je le prends aussi
les passions politiques étaient plus
moderne où on en est
des progrès supplémentaires j'ai
l'impression que parfois la politique
aggrave les le traitement
l'administration la gestion des
problèmes au lieu de l'améliorer st il
ya beaucoup de sueur sur le sujet
beaucoup d' à l'aide d'un amalgame le
1er janvier 2014
si j'ai bien saisi il ya schengen et
l'union européenne les frontières ne
tombe pas de la roumanie les frontières
roumaine et bulgare elle reste de
l'europe ne tombe pas mais les
travailleurs de ces états pourront
travailler en france par exemple sans
aucune restriction
c'est bien ça voilà on est en train de
débit quelques chemins de tout mélanger
pour que pour faire plus clair la chose
le 1er janvier 2014
c'est une date importante parce qu'il y
aura plus de restrictions pour les
travailleurs venus de roumanie et de
bulgarie sur le marché unique
il y avait des restrictions introduit
dans le traité d'adhésion de ces deux
pays mais après sept ans c'est parce
qu'il y aura six ans après notre entrée
tout cela tombait donc ça concerne tous
les tous les roumains tous les bulgares
non seulement les roms qui vient d'aider
ces pays mais c'est quelque chose qui
était qui a été convenu au moment de
notre antenne union le schengen ses
autres dossiers le schengen est
conditionné pour la roumanie par des
questions liées à la justice par dans le
cadre du mécanisme de coopération de
vérification ça n'a pas de lien avec
avec les roms ou spécialement avec les
roms une autre partie de la population
et enfin je le dis il n'y a pas de
de l'apport non plus entre les roms et
schengen donc quand je vois des
politiques
français mais aussi romain qui nie les
deux je me dis qu'il faut revenir à la
lecture des traités merci cristian preda
pour cet éclairage et maintenant
direction l'espagne troisième
exportateur de vin derrière la france et
l'italie et le pays espère bien devenir
le premier les exportations sont en
hausse comme dans d'autres domaines que
le tourisme par exemple un signe de
prospérité va-t-on vers une sortie de
crise en espagne
restons prudents et regardant le sujet
de rim benameur
chaque année c'est le même rituel à
logroño dans le nord de l'espagne
fin septembre les habitants foule les
grappes de raisin pieds nus un geste
symbolique pour lancer la période des
vendanges
pendant cinq jours toute la ville est en
fête c'est le moment de l'année le plus
important pour logroño capital de
l'année aura la région viticole la plus
célèbre d'espagne avec ses 1200 bodega
l'équivalent de nos domaines à quelques
kilomètres de là la bodega art a dit
aujourd'hui son propriétaire points de
carlos lopez de la calle accueil simone
field l'un de ses plus gros clients
anglais et fournisseurs notamment de la
reine d'angleterre
au programme visite guidée des vignes si
nous avons un bon mois de septembre nous
avons de bonnes pages septembre c'est la
clé de toute la récolte convaincre
l'acheteur étranger de la qualité de ses
vins un impératif pour quan carlos
depuis le début de la crise il a tout
misé sur l'exportation
plus de 85% des ventes se font à
l'international nos clients ne sont plus
seulement espagnol seulement européen il
y à des américains des canadiens et
chinois des thaïlandais s'étend dans le
monde entier des petits marchés avec les
petits volumes de ventes
tout est donc fait pour séduire les
clients
même un taxi anglais pour les
transporter direction la cave pour une
dégustation des meilleurs vins produits
ces dernières années des bouteilles
entre 17 et 450 euros grave on sent la
minéralité et la fraîcheur des
un goût d'agrumes c'est plus un moment
crucial c'est là que l'acheteur décide
s'il choisira à nouveau la bodega art a
dit comme fournisseur l'an prochain nous
avons découvertes d'excellents
producteurs pendant votre voyage ici
c'est 20 des saveurs qu'on associe à des
people tempéré et qui ont un vrai style
terroir avant les vins espagnols étaient
bon marché est même considéré comme bas
de gamme il était très alcoolisé est
aujourd'hui on du corps et peuvent tenir
la comparaison avec les meilleurs vins
de bordeaux et de bourgogne privilégié
l'exportation une stratégie économique
qui s'est généralisé dans la région même
pour les plus petites propriétés
pablo est un précurseur il a deviné
cette tendance il y a des années en 94
il crée les bodegas tellement rodriguez
avec son associé est d'essayer de vendre
100% de son vin à l'étranger des vins
originaux avec des raisins issus de
plusieurs parcelles une technique rare
en hesbaye
comme nous avons eu beaucoup de succès
avec notre premier vin vendu à
l'étranger
nous avons continué comme ça on se
disait que la vente en espagne viendrait
après finalement la crise nous étions
contents de plus de 80% de notre chiffre
d'affaires début la bodega vont beaucoup
en europe suisse autriche grande
bretagne mais c'est bien sûr vers les
pays émergents comme la chine ou la
russie que son regard se tourne
et comme elle pour conquérir ces
nouveaux territoires les vins espagnols
mise désormais plus sur la qualité que
sur la quantité
pour ce spécialiste du vin 2012 est
l'année de tous les records
la tendance de cette année c'est une
croissance en valeur avec plus de
rentrées d'argent quasiment 250 à 260
millions d'euros avec une baisse des
volumes
ce sont donc les prix qui ont augmenté
de 30% en moyenne
l'espagne a donc de quoi se réjouir
aujourd'hui le pays est le troisième
exportateur mondial devant derrière la
france et l'italie pour l'instant mais
avec la plus grande superficie
cultivable d'europe des vins abordables
et de qualité
l'espagne espère bientôt devenir
première et ainsi battre sa rivale de
toujours dans ce domaine la france
voilà un reportage signé à rim benameur
deux invités nous ont rejoints sur ce
plateau griselda pastor vous êtes
journaliste à la radio espagnole cadena
ser l'une des plus grandes radios en
espagne bonjour avec nous également juan
prat ancien ambassadeur d'espagne vieux
routier de la commission européenne est
aujourd'hui consultant merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors on l'a vu
dans le reportage de rym ben ameur le
vin en espagne ça marche ça dope la
balance commerciale est ce que c'est un
signe de reconquête signes de sortie de
crise
les ald am3 les femmes d'abord je vais
je vais dans le reportage ya des mots
que je déteste plus à ce moment présent
qui est le mot compétitivité donc le mot
compétitivité dans la pratique veut dire
moins cher pour beaucoup d'ouvriers en
espagne ça veut dire moins de salaire
pour beaucoup de gens savent où lui dire
pendant ces années de crise chômage donc
c'est pas l'état du vent c'est un très
bon vent au général et peut-être il
devient compétitif de plus en plus mais
je dois vous dire la situation de
l'espagne n'est pas facile encore soyons
clairs crois pas que vous avez trouvé
des choses intéressantes dans ce
reportage
oui ben j'ai trouvé que il y a beaucoup
d'innovations dont la production
traditionnelle espagnole
les vingt sept une production
traditionnelle et je connais très bien
vous connaissez le domaine où ce secteur
est pourquoi est-ce qu'on exporte
beaucoup c'est parce qu'on produit
beaucoup mieux parce qu on commercialise
beaucoup mieux et aussi pourquoi est-ce
qu'on exporte beaucoup plus parce que le
marché espagnol n'est plus en mesure
acheter tout ce que produisent nos
producteurs qui sont nombreux car il ya
eu beaucoup de nouvelles régions en
espagne sont ouvertes à la production de
vin traditionnel mot stellarium y en a
beaucoup plus maintenant dans tous les
coins de l'espagne grâce aux nouvelles
technologies
on produit du bon vin est donc
évidemment il fallait aller chercher à
l'extérieur
donc c'est un très bon exemple que vous
avez trouvé alors une question que j'ai
envie de vous poser à vous deux
questions tout ça parce qu'aujourd'hui à
l'heure actuelle l'espagne est sortie de
la crise non je crois que nous allons
créer ainsi des noms c'est long c'est
difficile il faut prendre seulement les
données des institutions officielles si
on suit le fonds monétaire international
la croissance de l'espagne va être
immense jusqu'en 2018
la meilleure date qui nous offre pour
cette année c'est presqu'un - déboursant
un rouge
j'suis pas si vous voyez combien
d'années de sacrifices qu'on a déjà
derrière des réformes structurelles deux
enfants nous on n'est pas sorti de la
crise et le problème c'est qu'on ne sait
pas dans quelles conditions je dis pas
économique parce que c'est parce que son
économie dans quelles conditions
sociales comme société on sait quand on
arrivera au bourg c'est la grosse
question qu'on se pose à ce moment c'est
vrai on a dit il alimente les deux non
on n'est pas sorti de la crise qui veut
pas dire qu'on ne voit pas quand même
une situation meilleure aujourd'hui
qu'il ya un an il y a deux ans l'espagne
a fait des efforts considérables ces
dernières années pour sortir de cette
crise donc il faut quand même qu'on voit
des fruits et le peuple espagnol est un
peuple qui endurent très bien toutes ces
crises on l'a vu parce que si vous allez
en espagne et vous savez quels sont les
chiffres de chômage qui en espagne et de
chômage des jeunes
vous attendez à voir une instabilité
sociale terrible 26 % taux de chômage 50
% des vieux mais pour 7% de chômage
excuse moi et 57% de jumelage parmi le
gène mois d'août d'après les dernières
données de le statut
malgré ça vous allez en espagne donc on
ne vous ne trouvez pas une espagne qui
est en effervescence sociale constante
dans la rue comme vous pouvez simplement
grinçant sont donc quand même ça veut
dire que il ya une endurance de société
on supporte tout ça petit à petit on
voit des signes et les jambons à
attendre à ce que ceux ci se produisent
maintenant comme je le disais évidemment
il y a les données macroéconomiques qui
sont un peu meilleures mais les données
macroéconomiques ce sont des
statistiques
l'important c'est le social là je coince
et dans lesquels on n'a pas encore
trouvé la solution pour faire face à ce
chômage énorme le canard et là c'est une
restucturation qu'il faut faire de
l'économie du pays très importante
n'est ce pas une réforme structurelle
qui déjà en train de se produire mais
qu'il faut encore aboutir que ça passe
encore là ne pas me laisser les
scénarios de sortie crise qu elle ce
qu'elle quel rôle des institutions
européennes ont joué aux pessimistes
politique de rigueur ça fait souffrir
c'est pas seulement parce que ce soit
une politique de rigueur
peut-être une politique de rigueur peut
être nécessaire en temps c'est
l'expliqué la justifier et donner des
espoirs pour l'avenir
rien de tout cela n'a été fait est sensé
tous union européenne ont des visages
grille est plutôt effacé malheureusement
40 milliards injectés banques espagnoles
oui bien sûr j'ai barriac aux banques
mais pas la population mais écoutez
c'est difficile à comprendre tout ça
pousse et qui sont en train de s'ouvrir
le chemin
pour ce qu'ils voient comment il va
fermer son petit magasin pour ceux qui
voient que tout d'un coup ils n'ont pas
d'argent pour payer le médicament ou où
il voit comme l'école où les amener sur
l'enfant ou bien doit fermer ou bien
doit changer
non les institutions ou jouer un rôle
mauvais parce que ils ont joué le rôle
de la rigueur mais ça me faire la
politique nécessaire pour qu'on puisse
comprendre et ça c'est pas seulement que
ça a aidé au gouvernement à faire plus
facile c'est qu'il devait faire aux deux
gouvernements qu'on aille parce qu'on a
commencé tout ça avec le socialiste
oulémas marine populaire salaires a fait
la chose plus facile mais à long terme
ça peut être très mauvais pour tout le
monde
vous êtes d'accord pas complètement je
ne dirais pas je ne qualifierais pas la
politique européenne comme mauvaise mais
comme peut-être pas toujours adaptés aux
besoins des différents pays le problème
que nous avons eu ces dernières années
c'est que la politique économique et
financière est allé vers
ce qui est ce qu'on considérait
nécessaires de la part de certains
grands pays l'espagne malheureusement a
perdu la possibilité d'introduire ses
visions là dedans
et effectivement c'est une question
aussi de communication les espagnols
n'ont pas très bien compris pourquoi est
ce qu ont mené certaines politiques et
l'espagne qui a été le pays qui est
entré à l'union européenne les
communautés européennes à l'époque
j'étais là par unanimité a toujours été
un pays très pro-européens et ces
dernières années eh bien la confiance en
des institutions européennes a diminué
mais ça ne veut pas dire que vous
trouviez en espagne aujourd'hui comme
d'autres pays européens des grandes
masses anti-européenne ou eurosceptiques
vous trouvez pas ça comme au royaume-uni
par exemple qui en bénéficient beaucoup
plus de l'union européenne que nous et
pourtant des zelda je vous interromps
parce que notre reportage on a
l'habitude d'interviewer quelqu'un de le
mettre en avant et il vous interpeller
vous pose une question
alors là on a interrogé un viticulteur
et vous allez voir sa question c'est pas
de l'économie ça va vous plaire griselda
écouter
dans la liesse
quand est ce que les lois et les normes
et les philosophies de cette société
avant de se préoccuper plus des hommes
et de leur valeur de leurs nécessités
économiques à court et à long terme
alors là l'impression je vous vois rire
qu'en période de crise sont les chiffres
les chiffres les chiffres et on oublie
l'humain les zelda wii là on est
d'accord on voulait les mains ça c'est
vrai mais en parlant de l'humain on
parle beaucoup du chômage des jeunes qui
est un drame et qui est le plus visible
mais je trouve que la crise espagnole du
point de vue économique le plus grave
c'était qu'elle a fait a tué énormément
de petites entreprises et les petites
entreprises sont le coeur de l'économie
d'un pays
et aujourd'hui ce qui disparaît surtout
sont des petites entreprises
et ça ça va être très difficile à
récupérer contre une petite entreprise
meurt mais très longtemps en créer une
autre à lons le chômage des jeunes c'est
terrible on pourra peut-être trouver des
solutions pour la création de nouvelles
entreprises
ça ça va être beaucoup plus difficile le
chômage déjà d'autant plus terrible
qu'on a vu qu'on appelle en algérie au
maroc
al-agha à l'envers des espagnols vont au
maroc pour aller travailler surtout dans
la construction c'est quoi le maroc
nouvel eldorado espagnol on a pu lire
dans la presse cette semaine c'est la
première fois que l'argent qu'ils
retournent à l'espagne est plus fort que
leur client qui sort des immigrés qui
sont venus travailler en espagne vers
l'extrême étrangers c'est la première
fois que ça arrive depuis 2002 puis je
me mets donc que nous
franchement j'aimerais pouvoir répondre
à la question quand est ce que les
citoyens seront l'objectif central de la
politique européenne
mais pour répondre à cette question il
faut des nouveaux politiciens et il faut
de citoyen qui ne se laisse pas faire
quand je mens capable économique et pas
assez politique pas assez social
l'europe sociale de jacques delors on a
fait une europe qu'à ce moment là n'est
pas pressé pour résoudre la question de
citoyens parce que le problème de
l'argent est plus important et plus fort
ça vous le savez malheureusement
j'insiste il faut pas se laisser faire
il faut se plaindre mais fort parce que
sinon on changera pas sa les semaines a
décidé de changer de fuseau horaire se
placer sur le fuseau horaire de des
royaumes unis pour améliorer la
productivité qu'est ce que cela vous
inspire
c'est une moi j'aime bien qu'il change
ses horaires je trouve que c'était une
bêtise d'avoir celui que nous avions
mais non mais je ne crois pas que ça va
changer énormément ça va être plus
commode pour les espagnols je crois mais
ça ne va pas être quelque chose qui va
changer la la situation économique du
pays mais je crois qu'il faut quand même
parler de l'avenir aussi n'est ce pas
nous sommes en train de voir un présent
un présent qui est très dur 1
un passé récent qui était encore plus
dur mais quand même moi je vois je vois
un avenir pas proche approche mais dans
un temps deux ou trois ans on devra
quand même voir voir les résultats d'une
politique très durs qu'a menées le
gouvernement mais c'est sûr qu'on verra
quand même un changement les gens
commencent à le sentir et ça c'est
important parce qu'aujourd'hui dans un
monde de communication
ce qui est important c'est ce qu'on voit
et pas ce qui est la réalité donc il
faut que certains changements
merci à vous d'avoir accepté le débat
c'est énorme habitations merci à vous
tous et la fin d'europe hebdo vous
retrouver la semaine prochaine n'aura
hamadi au parlement européen à
strasbourg cette fois d'ici là bonne
suite des programmes sur sur les chaînes
parlementaires